wes quand même par le kart 7 mois [ __ ]
merde je te demande juste un truc
dernier à mon pote
tiens voilà miraculé c'est génial
en fait c'était en pension au minou sa
bibliothèque un gel de savoir de quoi tu
vas la remplir je suis bien fermer sa
gueule salut c'est super mais qu'est ce
qui te marrer mais qu'est ce que t'as
jamais rien dit je te connais par
automoto
regarde moi ça s'appelle pas en vert on
dirait que le pilote a pas leur forme
est pas là sa force avait plus à ça vous
présente le commodore change de vie
samedi dernier était sauvée samedi la
tâche est un bateau samedi prochain tu
pars pars ou faire le tour du monde mon
pote c'est un rêve de môme ce quoi ce
que je sais à quoi tu avais un tonneau
jean 35 ans il a raison un peu chez moi
je rêvais quand j'étais vous vous
serviez brion gysin cancer m
respectivement à vue dont merde
mourir quoi qu il en train de mourir
regardez a menti depuis le début
est ce qu'on peut se parler une seule
fois et se dire la vérité je t'aime
au système
si un jour il arrive quelque chose ça me
touchait pas plus tard roche cubain
je passe je vais partir fois que je fais
une connerie je devrais faire c'est
passé un bon bout de temps ensemble
piquante et brenda to fail il faut que
je dise quelque chose avant de partir
ma seule famille
e